repasemos lo que ya hemos aprendido y
ojalá que todo esto se conecte para
entender un poco mejor luego haremos un
montón de cálculos con números reales y
creo que realmente entenderemos el punto
bueno en primer lugar déjenme dejan
escribirlo vamos a hacer algunas
columnas podríamos estar tratando con
digamos el concepto ajá
y luego diremos que estamos y estamos
tratando por ejemplo con una población
baja
población o con una muestra
o con una muestra el primer concepto
estadístico que surgió fue el de la idea
de la media o de la tendencia central y
hemos aprendido que es una manera de
medir el la tendencia central de un
conjunto de datos verdad otras maneras
serán la mediana y la moda pero la media
se muestra mucho mucho más especialmente
cuando hablamos de diferencias y de la
desviación estándar pero la media de una
población y vamos a utilizar la letra
griega miu es igual a la suma de todos
los datos de la población
déjenme déjenme asegurar que se parezca
como una y entonces sumamos todos estos
datos empezando con el primero de ellos
hasta el enésimo verdad suponemos que
hay n en la población y además se divide
por n y este es el promedio que estamos
acostumbrados a tomar antes de haber
aprendido cosas de estadística verdad se
agregan todos los datos se suman y se
divide entre todos los números que hay
en la muestra es es muy parecido a la
media solo que vamos a escribirlo con
con x barrita jaja y esto es igual a la
suma de todos los datos en la muestra
cada uno de los elementos de la muestra
pero estamos suponiendo que la muestra
es mucho menor que la población verdad y
empezamos en el primero y terminamos
hasta el enésimo donde n minúscula debe
ser más chica que n mayúscula no digo
puedes pueden ser iguales pues entonces
estaríamos hablando de del mismo
concepto y luego dividimos entre el
número de datos verdad que era n
entonces dijimos lo que ya está donde
esto nos da la tendencia central 10 es
una medida pero que si quisiéramos saber
un buen indicador
o algo que en promedio nos diga cuánto
nos estamos separando de esta muestra y
por eso es que escribimos el concepto de
varianza
y en una población la varianza tiene
notación sigma cuadrada esto es la
varianza
y esto tomamos de cada uno de los datos
tomamos cada uno de los datos
restamos de la media que se calculó
arriba lo elevamos al cuadrado para
obtener la diferencia cuadrada y a
continuación se toma el promedio de
todas estas medidas entonces sumamos
todas ellas desde la primera hasta la
última digamos hasta n y dividimos por n
esa es la varianza y a continuación
lamar la varianza muestral es un poco
más interesante y hablamos un poco de
ello en el último vídeo porque realmente
deseamos proporcionar deseamos estimar
la varianza de la población cuando
tomamos una muestra y a fin de
proporcionar una estimación sin sesgo es
algo muy parecido aquí pero dividimos
entre n menos 1 así que permítanme
anotarlo la varianza de una muestra o la
varianza muestral vamos a escribirlo
como como s s cuadrada
va a ser igual tomamos igual la
diferencia de la del promedio en este
caso de la media muestral y si suponemos
por supuesto que no conocemos la lámina
media porque si tuviésemos esa pues no
no no no tendríamos mucho que hacer pero
cuando tenemos una muestra la única
manera de calcular la media de población
es estimar con una media muestra y por
eso suponemos que sólo tenemos este este
parámetro
entonces sumamos estas medidas desde 1
hasta hasta n porque tenemos n datos y
dividimos si queremos tener una
estimación sin sesgo por n 1 y hablamos
un poco de esto de por qué dividimos
entre n menos 1 y en unos vídeos más
adelante voy a probar esto para usted
bueno voy a probarlo experimentalmente
usando excel y luego bueno no sería una
prueba sino cachar intuición pero luego
lo haré de formalmente no tienen que
preocuparse de saura
la próxima cosa que vamos a aprender y
esto lo van a escuchar muchísimo sobre
todo de sus profesores es de la
desviación estándar y quizás es la
palabra más utilizada de toda la
estadística y creo que mucha gente
desgraciadamente lo utiliza
sin apreciar plenamente todo lo que lo
que implica la desviación estándar pero
la meta será que finalmente apreciemos
todo lo que implica
y vamos a tratar de hacerlo pronto
entonces la desviación estándar
y una vez que sepa lo que es la
desviación estándar van a ver que es
algo muy sencillo en realidad es la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza
por eso vamos a escribir que la
desviación estándar es sigma que es
realmente la raíz cuadrada de sigma
cuadrada ahora ya entienden por qué la
varianza se escribe como sigma cuadrada
y esto es tomar la raíz cuadrada de esta
expresión que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada espero me quepa de la suma
desde uno hasta n de x y menos mío
al cuadrado
/ n todo esto entre n y entonces si
deseamos calcular la desviación estándar
muestral en realidad aquí aquí es donde
se pone más interesante aquí la
desviación estándar es la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza muestral pero esto no es
un estimador in sesgado y no quiero
llegar a puntos técnicos por ahora solo
créanme que esto es una buena estimación
para el valores de esperado después voy
a voy a ir con más profundidad en esta
cuestión de los valores esperados pero
resulta que este parámetro no es no es
parecido a este de la desviación
estándar así que porque quisiera hablar
de la desviación estándar bueno en
realidad si hablamos de de unidades
resulta mucho mejor por ejemplo si
tomamos medidas en longitud de metros
entonces la unidad de la varianza sería
el cuadrado de los metros verdad porque
tomamos metros menos metros y al
cuadrado obtenemos metros cuadrados y es
un concepto un poco extraño
la dispersión promedio de la de la media
en realidad cuando tomamos la raíz
cuadrada si teníamos metros cuadrados
para la bia la varianza entonces ya
estamos recuperando la unidad de metros
verdad entonces poco a poco vamos a ir
aprendiendo cómo modelar datos como una
curva de campana y algunas veces revela
cosas interesantes acerca de todas estas
cuestiones de la probabilidad podemos
encontrar la desviación estándar de la
media en fin de todos modos no quiero ir
al punto técnico ahora solo voy a hacer
unos cálculos unos cálculos muy
sencillos vamos a calcular digamos
supongamos que tengo los números 1 2 3 8
y 7 y supongamos que todo esto es una
población así que cuál sería su media
bueno sería uno más 2 más 3 y esto es 3
más 3 son 6 más 8 son 14 y 7 son 21
21 así que la media la media de esta
población es tomamos todos los datos y
los sumamos que son 21 y dividimos entre
el número de datos que son 1 2 3 4 5
ahora 21 entre 5 pues es 4.2
muy bien ahora queremos averiguar la
varianza y supone que bueno vamos a
hacer la varianza de toda esta población
verdad entonces la sigma cuadrada va a
ser la suma de las diferencias cuadradas
de cada dato de la media va a tener que
sacar mi calculadora después esto va a
ser 1 menos 4.2 al cuadrado más 2 menos
4.2 al cuadrado más 3 menos 4.2 al
cuadrado
8 - 4.2 al cuadrado más 7 menos 4.2 al
cuadrado y esto se va a ver muy chistoso
pero todo esto vamos a dividirlo entre
el número de datos que son 5
así que permítanme ahora sacar la
calculadora muy bien
ok
y aquí vamos en realidad creo que debía
haber utilizado más bien la calculadora
gráfica que tengo déjenme ver si puedo
conseguir esta cosa
déjenme ver
ok
ahí está y creo que la gráfica será
mejor porque puedo ver todo lo que
escribo
aunque déjenme borrar todo quiero
aprovechar el 1 - 4.2 y todo esto al
cuadrado más
más aquí está
2 - 4.2 y todo esto al cuadrado más 3
menos 4.2 al cuadrado
todos al cuadrado más 8 menos 4.2 al
cuadrado a cuenta que solo estoy tomando
la suma de las distancias de los datos a
la media verdad y eso al cuadrado y me
faltó sumar 7 menos 4.2 al cuadrado es
la suma 38.8 entonces el numerador va a
ser igual a 38.8 y va a ser dividido por
5 verdad esto fue la suma de las
distancias cuadradas cada una de ellas
es mi x y menos 1000 al cuadrado verdad
tomamos la suma de todos ellos y este
numerador es la suma de cada una de las
equis y menos mil al cuadrado y esto es
de 1a
n en este caso en el 5 terminó haciendo
38.8 verdad sólo tome cada uno de los
datos menos la media los agregue en la
formulita y conseguí 38.8 y le faltó
dividir entre 5 ok
aquí la genera 5 verdad así 38.8 / 5 es
7.76
7.76 así que la varianza permiten
permiten inscribir una abajo la varianza
de 7.76
ahora si esto era una parte de una
distribución mayor sí sí en realidad
esto es una muestra y no fuera el total
de la población entonces nuestra muestra
en realidad para sacar la la varianza
muestral tendríamos que dividir 38.4
perdón perdón 38.8 y no dividir entre 5
sino dividir entre 4 verdad 10 9.7
ahí está la varianza muestrales 9.7
pero bueno de todos modos no se
preocupen ahora por eso solo es cambiar
la n por una vez que tenemos la varianza
podemos calcular la desviación estándar
verdad sacamos la raíz cuadrada de 7.76
y nos da dos puntos 78 más bien 2.79
redondeando verdad y esta es la
desviación estándar así que nos da
cierto grado en promedio de cuánto los
números se alejan de la media que fue
4.2 y le da en las unidades de la medida
original de todos modos y nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo oper perfect solo me
faltó ver qué pasa con si bueno si
teníamos la varianza muestral y que era
era 9.7 como lo calculamos hace ratito
entonces la desviación estándar de la
muestra va a ser la raíz cuadrada de eso
la raíz cuadrada de 9.7 que sería 3.1
3.11
de todos modos ojalá que esto haga más
sentido no nos hemos estado ocupando de
este tipo de variables así que realmente
lo que hacemos con números no es tan
difícil de todos modos nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo